and the race to discover who will be the
next leader of u-kiss under way and with
the backing of the party's key donor
Aaron banks it looks like Rahim kasam is
the front-runner one of the candidates
Suzanne Evans who today confirmed her
own candidacy said that she feared he
would take the party in what's called a
far-right direction while mr. Kazan
joins me now very good morning - morning
Kazan well let's say respond directly
that's hear it from you from Suzanne
Evans she talked about that far right
direction she also talked about not
wanting that kind of toxicity in the
party I don't want this to be about
personal attacks and I was disappointed
that 60 seconds into her campaign launch
she makes it a personal attack on me I
think this is about the future of the
party I certainly do not consider myself
far right and I think she never
considered me far right when she asked
my help writing UKIP's manifesto in 2015
so this is just this is just politics
and I want to get away from that and I
want to want to talk about what the
future the party should be and what the
future of the country should be so I'm
gonna say to her let's stop all of that
let's come together as people who
believe in Britain and actually knock
our heads together and come up with the
right solutions she can meet me whenever
she wants but you think she's an asset
to the party I think she can be I think
there's no well I think there's no doubt
when she goes in front of television
cameras and and takes the party line on
things and she can present them in a
very reasonable and good way but when
she does things like this it really
undermines her it undermines her
campaign and it's attack on a lot of the
party members there was a YouGov study
that came out today that showed that the
party likes the direction that Nigel
Faraj has taken it in they don't want to
compromise on that and she's talking
about compromising on it and being the
centrist party and I'm here to say that
I would continue Nigel Farage's legacy
inside you Kim but I mean you're not a
unifier are you I mean you're pretty
forthright about many of the
personalities and members of the party I
mean are you serious about trying to
unify the party or wouldn't you just
want to get rid of them I'm deadly
serious if these people like me by the
way can be penitent sinners and say
we've said some things in the past that
we don't wish to stand so I've seen is
that the most as well I think a lot of
us are I think a lot of us are and I'm
putting myself in that but I think now
especially after that incident with
Stephen wolf in the European Parliament
we have to say this has gone too far we
are all in the same party and if we wish
to remain in the same party let's sit
down around
altogether set in 2015 after the general
election looking at much of you keep in
thinking you are just a bunch of ragtag
unprofessional embarrassing people who
let Nigel down at every juncture saying
things have changed or you've got to
sort that out now who needs sorting out
it really does need sorting out
somebody's gonna have to go
well this is why well some structures
need changing the party needs a
professional management board it's it's
ludicrous that you have elected members
of the National Executive Committee who
fight their own seats across the country
in charge of the finances and in charge
of campaign strategy because they're
gonna favor their own seats and their
own campaigns it needs professional
management board and yes that means some
of the NEC powers will have to go and
the NEC should be turned into a regional
representation for the party so yes I am
the only candidate I truly believe I'm
the only candidate who's willing to go
in there and say this needs real change
okay so if some of them can't deal with
that they go and then you'd bring in the
likes of Tommy Robinson I saw an
interesting video of you on on YouTube
chocolate quite recently about Tommy
Robinson of course this former leader of
the English Defence League now leading
or involved in pegida in the UK and you
say you would consider having him in UK
no I've never said that what I've said
is he said he's a friend of yours well
I've said well actually what I've said
he's is a great source because I'm a
journalist I'm still a journalist I'm
doing that I have to get in there I have
to get into these rallies and I report
on them and we video them and we
interview people and I've interviewed
him twice now and I actually even I will
say this myself I actually stood up at
the pagina rally and gave a speech about
brexit about brexit because it was a
head of the EU referendum Holly Robinson
wouldn't have a place in the UK
Independence Party
I believe he's even said that himself
unless he changes no no no see my policy
on the blanket ban inside your cube has
been very clear from day one and you get
all of the other candidates trying to
spin it to journalists this is our
politics works my policy has been very
very clear is that if you want to pay
for your own CRB check your own
disbarment service check then the party
can sit you in front of a panel and you
can make your case to them but let me
ask you this question if you don't mind
how many how many members of the
far-right do you think you're going to
join a party led by a chap called Raheem
kasam bupkis well you said your friends
were Tommy Robinson I mean he looks like
a member of the far-right to me well I
think what Tommy did when he left the
EDL was try and sever that
That's not me defending him I just I'm
interpreting that as a journalist now do
you think you've got the temperament to
do this job I mean I've been reading
your Twitter feed as well and you know I
mean it may have been late at night the
one I read when you're having an
exchange with is they call the patrols
perhaps who are having a go at you you I
think you're watching news night
together you were using the C word the F
word the S word you were barring people
do you think you could restrain yourself
if you became leader you know my job has
been to be a very combative journalist
my job has been to be a little bit out
there a little bit a little bit you know
get some attention things like that but
nowadays you know 21st century we live
our lives in short bursts you know I've
been a journalist I've been a think-tank
ER I've been a comms director I've
worked for Nigel Farage you know you
move on and you can you can be different
people in your life I haven't sat here
my whole life and gone I want to aspire
to be a politician and therefore I'm
going to carry myself like a PC robot
I've been a normal human being
and your question was when you use
anglo-saxon sweats if people know of
course not but people use that kind of
language you know walk down any high
street with me you can hear it you know
we're not none of us are beyond making
mistakes like that but it's about being
able to own up to them and say look you
know I've done that I'm not going to do
that now I listen to this interview you
know go away and look at my other
interviews on television it's not that
is it now talk about the policies and
we've got to talk about a Calais and
your your view on the child refugees
coming I mean you obviously don't
believe some of them are children for a
start well I would like I would like the
evidence as all I'm saying you know I
think we're just acting yeah I think so
I think there has to be and I would
actually like that to be transparent
process I would like these records to go
up on the government website obviously
redacted we don't want their faces we
don't want the names attached these
things but we can show that these tests
have been done if the government can
prove to the British public and calm all
of this stuff down then why doesn't it
just do it okay and what about Gary
Lineker I mean he's been very voluble in
supporting people whatever actually I
said it's basic humanity to be concerned
about our fellow individuals in the
world people are saying well he's
straight across the line you should be
sacked by the BBC what's your view well
I have never been a big fan of people
who are in different industries and
sports industry and things I like timing
in on Paula
I think they they're more than welcome
to you know just I just don't think they
have all the facts to hand
I'm not a big Walker's fan I prefer the
real McCoy okay well you'll see
pre-prepared that but you think you
should say no I didn't know you should
he still be employed by the BBC that's a
decision for the BBC to take out you
know they have their own structures
inside determining whether or not their
people should do this sort of thing I'm
like I don't care personally I did it's
not a big issue for me
you know Gary Lineker now trained Kazan
thank you very much indeed